project Q is real it has now been
officially confirmed by Sony but who the
heck is this device actually for today
we'll discuss what it is what it isn't
an attempt to understand why PlayStation
is even bothering with this in the first
place so to start we actually need to go
back to April 5th because that's when
Tom Henderson of Insider gaming broke
the story that Sony was working on a new
PlayStation handheld that would not be a
traditional handheld in the vein of a
PSP or a Vita and actually not even a
cloud gaming device but instead a remote
play only device that would always
require an internet connection to
function fast forward to the most recent
PlayStation showcase and Sony has pretty
much confirmed all of what was in
Henderson's original report we actually
had our first look here at the hardware
itself which literally looks as if they
cut a dual Sims controller in half and
then slapped an 8-inch HD screen right
in the middle that will play games via
remote play From A PS5 and up to 60
frames per second still no price or an
exact release date but the PS5 aspect
there is key because this device will
require a PS5 5 to function you have to
connect to a PlayStation 5 to play
anything this will not run native games
on its own now one of the cool things
about Remote Play if you've never used
it before you do not have to actually be
within close physical proximity to your
Playstation you can actually have your
PS5 at home and then you could be in a
totally different area as long as they
are both connected to the internet and
you've set up the remote play and all
that stuff then you would be able to
connect of course what is one of the
greatest strengths of Remote Play is
also one of the greatest weaknesses
because you are totally reliant on that
internet connection so if you have a
really slow connection if it's not a
reliable connection then your gameplay
is going to suffer and at least for me
I've not actually tried remote play in a
while but even in the most ideal
scenarios there is still always just a
little bit of an input lag now maybe
it's gotten better in recent years I
would hope so if they're making a whole
device dedicated to this so as I said I
don't use it much personally I think
Remote Play itself though is a really
nice to have feature kind of like an
add-on and it's actually something that
PlayStation has been really big on and
supporting all the way back since the
PSP and the PS3 then again with PS4 and
the Vita it was always just that a
feature and not the core function of the
device look here's the reality
PlayStation was burned pretty bad by the
Vita at least that's how they see it
from their point of view considering
sales numbers weren't what they hoped
now as a day one Vita owner myself I say
there was a lot more Sony could have
done to help make vita a success which I
still believe that was a device well
ahead of its time now what's funny is
that over the years since Sony stopped
making the PlayStation Vita it's gotten
more and more and more of a following
online as people have really started to
see how great this device can actually
be and the hardware itself is still
great today the reality is they released
the Vita in what was a very different
market and a very different time but now
we're again in a very different Market
the Nintendo switch is already one of
the top three best-selling consoles of
all time guys think about that and with
no success or insight for the immediate
near future of the Nintendo switch it
seriously could threaten the PS2 as the
best-selling console of all time there's
also the steam deck which of course not
nearly the sales numbers that the switch
has even though valve does not release
sales numbers the steam deck though as a
device has garnered praise from video
game enthusiasts and critics alike as
just a very well made device and what
both of these devices have in common is
that they aren't asking devs to develop
titles solely for the handheld as was
the case with the older handhelds like
the Vita with the incredible success so
far the PS5 just imagine for a moment
imagine a world if you will where Sony
announced a handheld device that could
play all the same games games you
already own on the PS5 albeit with some
downgrades to run effectively on the
handheld Hardware that's a device that
would be a for sure day one purchase for
me now I don't know about all the tech
behind it maybe people would say that
that would cost way too much all I know
is that steam deck is already doing it
right now with major titles running very
effectively on the hardware but instead
what we get is a device capable of
playing those PS5 games but only via
remote play which to me makes this
Hardware much closer to something like
Nintendo's failed Wii U as opposed to a
switch or steam deck competitor now for
one of the most head scratching Parts
about this is that PS5 already supports
remote play on laptops PCS tablets even
mobile phones devices that many of us
already have one or even multiple of you
can connect your dual sense wirelessly
on all of these they even have an
officially licensed backbone controller
that you can actually slot your iPhone
into to make it feel more like a true
handheld so Remote Play it's clearly
something they really care about as a
feature they've cared about it in the
past and they still care about it today
and I'll say I think it's great that
there are options out there for people
who really use that feature and who
really even in some cases rely on that
feature but I have to think that Gamers
who know they use Remote Play and really
enjoy using remote play on the PS5 don't
you guys already have a setup using some
of those devices that we just mentioned
that you're already happy with it seems
like Sony is really hoping the Dual
sense features and maybe the quality of
the screen will really win out here we
still don't know a lot about the quality
of the screen but I would assume that
it's going to be pretty good now to be
fair there's also another key part of
this that at the time of this recording
we still aren't sure about and that's
the price I hope I'm wrong on this guys
but I feel like the price of this thing
is going to shock people when they
finally announce it just starting as a
baseline we already know the price of a
dual Sims controller on its own it is 80
brand new as for the screen if you look
at modern tablets like the eight inch
Kindle Fire goes for about a hundred
dollars Amazon of course is known for
their really aggressive pricing another
thing to consider is The dualson's Edge
controller which Sony sells for 200 new
which by the way is the same price you
can buy a brand new Nintendo switch
light for so where will this new Remote
Play device sit in terms of pricing well
they try to get it below the Dual sense
Edge controller or is it going to be
just above the Dual sense Edge
controller for this thing to have any
chance at all I think they need to be
really aggressive with the pricing here
I think a starting price of 150 would be
ideal but I don't think there's any
chance whatsoever that it actually
releases for that I don't think it
releases for less than 200 I'd be
pleasantly surprised if it did anything
250 or more and I think that's going to
be really hard for the vast majority of
people who would be interested in this
thing to justify I mean remember guys
you already have to have a PS5 to use
this thing for it to function at all
another element that's working against
project Q is battery life which
reportedly lasts just three to four
hours now presumably you could plug it
in to keep playing but again then you
kind of lose some of the benefits of
having the freedom that you can move the
device around I do think there are a few
groups of people where a device like
this could be really useful for starters
if you're in a family setting with
multiple people sharing one TV this
would give Gamers a way to play even
While others are watching something
different on the TV people living in
small apartments or a college dorm
setting I could see it being useful
there as well but again the remote play
feature is all already possible with
devices that you likely already have I
guess it does provide a more all-in-one
solution with a singular Focus so it
keeps your other devices free and saves
you from draining their batteries if you
have the Q to use for gaming ultimately
this feels like an incredibly Niche
product the tech in it is pretty
straightforward though and not a lot of
new tech so hopefully there wasn't a lot
of r d costs associated with it Sony
also doesn't even have to worry about
any sort of dedicated support for this
device so it's not like they're going to
get burned like they did with vita
because just inherently it can play any
PS5 game but of course it requires that
system and an internet connection to be
able to do so and it doesn't run it
natively it's all over Remote Play I
have to wonder if if maybe they were
toying around with the idea of a true
successor to the PSP nvida but
ultimately scrapped it it's interesting
to see them put so much effort behind
psvr for example considering the sales
of it were not great at least I don't
think they were great just think of it
like this the PS Vita was considered a
commercial failure and it sold around 16
million units compare that to the last
official numbers we got for the first
generation PlayStation VR which only
sold 5 million units as we all know Sony
did make a successor to psvr and they're
currently making a strong push for psvr
too and again this is something that
requires a lot of software built from
the ground up specifically with VR in
mind and I have to admit I am totally
100 biased here I want to see a true
Sony handheld a true successor to PS
Vita and I'm also not the biggest fan of
VR but what about you guys out there I'd
really love to hear if any of you are
legitimately looking forward to project
Q let me know in the comments what are
your specific use cases where you think
this device would be really useful and
justify what could be a 200 to 250
dollar price tag if you want to see more
PlayStation content from me go ahead and
subscribe to the channel to let me know
that you'd like to see more videos like
this as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon